what's going on everyone entrepreneurs
uh and business owners my name is alex
ramose
i'm the ceo of allen prestige labs uh
gym launch
and a number of other portfolio
companies that we own um
what i want to give you today is one
very very simple hack
that we've used to consistently improve
our marketing uh neil patel said in one
of his keynote speeches that he believes
that the future
of marketing is going to exist in cro so
conversion rate optimization
and he said that because you know the
prices are going to only consistently go
up and it's most of
most platforms are based on an auction
which means that it's just multiple
businesses competing for the same
eyeballs
and so the people who are better able to
convert those eyeballs are going to be
the ones who are going to be able to out
compete and win obviously the model the
price points all the other stuff matters
but
the conversion rate in it of itself
matters a lot too now
there's a lot of parts in a pipeline
that exists from acquisition
but what i want to do is just give you
one thing uh from today's video that you
can
immediately implement and it's simple
that has worked and made us a lot of
money
all right the process is simple every
week
what we do is we have our marketing
meeting and we do
one split test just one
all right and that's because everyone
wants to test 100 things
but what it does is it forces us to be
very very focused on the one thing that
we think is going to drive
the highest result for us and the thing
is is that when you do this every single
week for 52 weeks in a row and you do
that for five years
your process just gets better and better
and better and those
increase those increases in conversion
compound all right
and so when we are running split tests
on marketing especially for paid
advertising
um i'll give you the two biggest things
that we look at all right
the first thing it sounds obvious and
simple but people don't do it
is we simply split test the headlines
on our landing pages that's it we simply
split test the headlines
the next thing that we'll split test is
going to be
the image that is underneath of the
headline all right
because what we've seen from the vast
majority of all of the tests that we've
done
is that almost all of the juice that's
going to come the biggest
jumps in conversion rate happen above
the fold and so when i say above the
fold it means like when you go on your
desktop and you go to a landing page
everything that you can see before
scrolling is above the fold when you go
to your
your phone um and you blend and you
you load a page everything you see
that's immediately available on the
screen
is above the fold and so that is where
that is where you're selling them on
whether they're going to stay on the
page and continue to read more
and that's where the biggest returns
will come from all right
and so we will split test almost every
week the the majority of our of our
tests will be
i would say 90 of our tests are either
headline or image tests
and that's it that's literally it um
sometimes
you know we'll actually because if if
we're changing a headline then the image
doesn't make sense
we'll do you know a new headline and
image against it against the old
headline
image and image but that will be the
entirety of the test and so
if you can implement this one process
into your marketing cadence so when you
meet with your marketing team
or if you're hopefully you know if
you're just doing the marketing for
yourself if you set this cadence on your
own calendar of every monday
we meet and we say what was last week's
test what was the winner
great did we beat the control if we
didn't beat the control
then we try another test right and the
thing is is when you do this on a
continuous basis
the business will continually improve
and so there's a million things you can
do
but what are the few things that you
should do that are going to drive the
biggest result because ultimately all of
us have the same amount of time every
day
and so it's the people who make the best
decisions who focus on the fewest
variables that make the biggest
difference right
one of the biggest things that drives me
nuts is when someone says
you know oh i said we should do that
ages ago
right which is one of the things by the
way for my team if anyone's listening
please don't do that it drives me nuts
there's a million things that we should
do right we should probably be better
about our follow-up we should probably
be doing more email marketing we should
probably be making more content well
obviously
but what of all of the things that we
can do given the resources time
effort and human capital that we have
and money are going to drive the biggest
result and so
when i think about all the different
things that we can improve on our
marketing standpoint
just doing this one thing will
consistently yield
better returns in terms of time and
effort and and the amount of time it
takes to do this and the amount of
return we get from it is
disproportionate and i see
even a lot of experienced you know
marketers and business owners uh who
don't do this you know what i mean and
i'm like
that's crazy you know why why would you
not do that and so
a simple process you can outline focus
on everything above the fold
usually headline sub-headline image
those are the things that are going to
be the things that drive the biggest
conversion rate optimization
and you know use this in the business
see the results for yourself and keep
being awesome and i'll catch you guys on
flip side
bye